[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the our speaker
this afternoon is press Mars Hallie an
institute professor who has been
associated with linguistics now
linguistics and philosophy and with RLE
he joined rld where as I did when Jerry
Wiesner was directing it 1951 so I've
known Morris since somewhat before that
but the overall of the years I think my
favorite quotation came from when he
received the Killian award and talked
about how he had become a linguist and
said that in his childhood in Latvia he
grew up in a household in which all the
adults spoke different like every adult
had a different language and he knew he
induced being an intelligent fellow he
induced from his surroundings that when
you grew up you got your own language
and it did happen but he never guessed
that his was going to be English he's
going to talk to us like a
representation of words in memory you
need a handout anybody here
you can't follow this without this
speech without the Handa where's now
yeah that's better
the light is so strong in speaking as
well as in listening to speech of others
we have the very clear and distinct
impression that all utterances are
composed of discrete words many people
are quite surprised when it's pointed
out to them that utterances are quasi
continuous acoustically and normally
contain no pauses separating one word
from the next the next and this
impression of speaking and hearing
discrete words in the continuous speech
signal is not lost even by the most
experienced speech researchers who are
completely aware that utterances are not
acoustically segmented into words now
there's more to it when I produce the
English utterance a dog never plays when
he's alone everyone in this room can not
only repeat it but when asked can easily
establish that the utterances consisted
of eight words a dog never plays when he
is alone on the other hand when I
produce the utterance pecci Nick Dini I
agree she assam
everyone in this room most people in
this audience will have difficulty in
repeating what I said and will find it
almost impossible to determine how many
words this utterance was composed of yet
you heard it just as clearly as the
other utterance I made
well there's of course no mystery about
the result of this little experiment the
second utterance was in check a language
that I suppose not many people in this
room command and since they did not know
check they couldn't they didn't know
they since they don't know check they
don't know the words of check and
knowledge of a language of course
crucial to all aspects of speech our
experiment also brings out the fact that
an essential aspect of the knowledge of
language is the knowledge of words now
most people think that that's all but
it's not true but and but I will not
enlighten you on that topic I will limit
I will perhaps reinforce the incorrect
impression that many of you may have
that knowing the words is all it's a
large part of what you have to do but
it's it isn't all now this is totally
unsurprising proposition however has a
number of corollaries that provide
helpful hints about the nature of
language perhaps the most important of
these for our topic is that we are not
born now in the words of our language
the words we we know we've learned from
our parents from other people from books
or other medium media so what does it
mean to know word when we learn or come
to know word we store in our memory
information of a certain kind that
enables us to use the word and not to
insist that we ourselves produce and to
recognize it when used in another's by
someone else the information that we
need in order to do this is of two kinds
on one hand we need information about
the sound of the word
let us call this the phonetic
information on the other hand we need
information about the meaning of the
word about its lexical category for
example we need to know is it a noun or
a verb or an adjective
yeah it's grammatical peculiarities for
example is it a strong or weak verb does
it form it's plural with the irregular s
as in cakes or keys or there is an
Amazon children and oxen let's call a
latter information grammatical semantic
information now the present talk will be
limited to the phonetic information I
shall have nothing to say next to
nothing to say about the other kind
though if anybody wants to talk about
I'm happy to answer questions about it
okay so now we know that we must store
in our memory since we did not ever
since we listen for the phonetic
information about every word now this
that is we're not born knowing it and if
you want to say dog or cat or table or
whatever you want to happen to want to
say you something has to be in your
memory to say it you don't say it I we
very rarely make up words for all
practical person we could say we never
make up words we always get them from
the outside
now this naturally reached other
questions to the form in which this
memory is stored in in the form in which
this information is stored in our memory
it has been assumed by most linguists
and other students of language that the
phonetic information about each word is
stored as a sequence of discrete units
called phonemes as the first
approximation we may think of the
phonemes as the units that are
represented by the letters in written
language thus the claim that is being
made here is that speakers of English
remember the word cat is being composed
of three phonemes whereas the word scat
is a sequence of four phonemes etc etc
now if we reflect on it a bit the
proposition that the words are composed
of phonemes is anything but self-evident
it implies that all speakers of all
languages store the words they know a
sequences of discrete letter sized units
perhaps the most dubious implication of
this proposition is that this must be
true also very young children say three
or years and younger for many of them
speak quite fluently if our claim is
correct they must be able not only to
split up into discrete words the
continuous speech that they hear but
they must also be able to segment the
words into phonemes such children must
therefore be able to perform
sophisticated analyses on the utterances
they hear that are beyond the
present-day capabilities of speech
science even worse perhaps even worse is
that there's nothing out there in the
world that might suggest a two-year-old
or to anyone for that matter that speech
consists of words and that words are
composed of phonemes you know this
discovery that the words are composed
the phonemes underlies alphabetic
writing and alphabetic writing wasn't
discovered till you know three thousand
years ago but human being has been
around and probably been speaking for
God knows maybe a million years we don't
I'm not anyway it's it's a relatively
recent discovery that sort of as a
conscious discovery yet as an
unconscious discovery if this claim is
true it must underlie all language at
all times now and this is rather
surprising and not yourself fr-from
self-evident so but how come that
somebody learns it since you know your
mother never tells you to study the
phonemes of your language and certainly
mothers maybe now you know recently they
were they become more anxious about
their children getting into kindergarten
but you know when even when I was a
child they did what people didn't worry
too much about it so of questions how
come that children even begin to get the
idea that they have to do that
well when you are asked when you're when
you are faced with unanswerable
questions the the obvious move there is
one standard move that every professor I
mean everybody knows and that is to
question the presuppositions so we
instead of answering the question we'll
say well what's the presupposition of
this question and maybe we can then
gather on now implicitly in this subject
in this question an objection is the
assumption that children need to learn
both that there are words and that words
are composed of phonemes instead I we
might assume something different and
here we follow a line of reasoning that
I like lots of what goes on here was
pioneered by Chomsky originally and
namely that this knowledge is hardwired
into all of us at birth and that the
knowledge that speech is composed of
phonemes is as much part of our
physiological makeup as our heart or
lungs and liver our language has a word
for such innate knowledge and that's the
word instinct and here I quote from the
Webster's third and it said that an
instinct is a complex and specific
response on the part of an organism to
environmental stimuli that is largely
hereditary and unalterable though the
pattern of behaviors through which it is
expressed may be modified by learning
that does not involve reason a learning
that does not involve reason and that
has its goal the removal of attention or
excitation well I mean if you if you're
if you have the instinct for chopping
words into phonemes well then you do
them and there's nothing to explain
that's the only way you can be because
that's that's what means what it means
to be in at least in Part B be human and
have have the capacity to learn language
so children now if this assumption is
correct learn words not because they're
taught to do so but rather because
they're constructed from birth so as to
do this and part of their innate
machinery can
of the mechanisms that analyze words
into its phonemes and of course we do
not know very much about these
mechanisms but that's what that's the
logic of the situation now there's even
some very simple experimental evidence
showing that very young English speaking
children analyze their words at the
phonemes the evidence involves the
ability of children to perform plurals
of nouns they know so in English the
plurals are formed as you all know by
adding s well that's not quite correct
if you look at the examples in - you
will see that they definitely differ
somewhat so it's very clear if you're
looking let's say to see that you don't
add just s you had B the word beach and
the plurals that is not beach but it's
beaches
you had a whole syllable and if you're
looking to be you don't add which is you
yeah but you had notice you don't say
keys you don't say place you say Kiki's
plays which is so you add there and
finally in in fact you do add ass just
in the case of the examples in 2a all
right so notice that there are three
distinct plurals not just one those of
you came and they better sit next to
somebody who has a handout I don't have
any more because you can't follow this
without the okay all right so there's
three suffixes and and you know the
children have to know which to say for
example if a child says Keese you'll
notice that there's something wrong with
the way the child speaks and mumble
might get anxious but children never do
that they always do they never say corta
if a child were to say cacus instead of
cakes you would notice that and child a
children
do they know how to say it correctly now
in fact it turns out that they that
these plural suffixes are not randomly
distributed you don't have to learn each
word with its plural but there is a
general rule and the rule is given in
one form of the rule we'll be talking
about this rule is given in 3 now what
it says there if the noun ends in
choo-choo sir sure sure
then the plural is us okay that's the
first part of the rule second part
otherwise if it doesn't end in this list
then if it ends in further add then adds
and finally otherwise adds so you have
like a decision tree you know check a
list you understand okay now okay so
this is a rule now the question is do
children know this rule or is this
something that's clever linguists
invented you know people who get PhDs
from MIT
well the answer is that children know
this rule and in fact there's an in in
the literature there's an experiment
that shows it and I experiments rather
I'll tell you a rather simple experiment
the sugar the experimenters have kind of
done every different kind of dolls and
they gave them names
so one name doll had the name was a cly
and another doll was a clich let's say
and another doll was his name was click
and now now obviously these are not
English words the children had never
heard these words the experimenters
never so they introduced these dolls to
the children and then they ran the
experiments and they were very careful
never to use plurals of these names and
then they arranged them in little groups
in this room where the experiment
the test was conducted the children were
brought in and rich and the child was
asked what's that you know pointing at a
group of dolls of one type and the child
would say these are the cly's or these
are whatever it was like I don't hear I
couldn't pass that test anyway but they
were an - over but here they were they
said the correct plural that is they
always there so for cly's they said
cly's for kalisch they said collisions
have four click they said flex you know
just like the way you're supposed to say
by this rule number three now notice
that they had not heard these these
names before these names weren't given
right there you know at the that's the
first time they ever heard and they had
certainly never heard the plural of
these words but they knew how to do that
now
the conclusion is of course that they
knew the rule but knowing the rule
implies a little bit more than that that
is they they not only did they know the
rule they could apply it and in order to
apply the rule of course what they had
to do is they had to slice the word up
into the last phoneme and the rest
minimally and then once they had done
that then they could pick the right
suffix namely whatever it was for each
of the three sets that this is given in
in your rule number three now so the
conclusion is that none of that children
have knowledge of the kind that
presupposes their ability to divide the
continuous speech signal up into words
and the words into phonemes and perform
these a rather complicated perhaps like
not so complicated but anyway these
tasks of making the plural
now let's now the next question that we
will briefly discuss is what what are
phonemes now when you study phonemes
i've given you a list of phonemes in
four
now this by their so book you know those
are the the so pill bill feel Vail mall
or something like these are the and and
similar to this and so on now when we
pronounce these forever as you study
these things you notice something that
when you pronounce these phonemes all
the ones that I've given you involve
complete closure as its closure of your
mouth so that the air is obstructed in
this flow in its outflow that's very
different let's say when you have other
phonemes like say ro or these vowels are
quite different from the constant since
I've given you and they all have this
the property that somehow there's an
obstruction yeah to the flow of air now
what differentiates these three groups
is the piece of machinery that you have
to that obstructs the flow so in the
first set put both former and so on it's
the lips in the second set it's the flat
part of the tongue the see it's not the
lips but it's the flat part of the
tongue and in the third set good girl
it's the body of the tongue that that
stopped saying that the airflow so you
have so they we have so we have three
groups depending on the P the
articulator is the class is the
technical term that interrupts the
airflow now in it so that's one property
that there's an the air flow is
interrupted and there's a particular
articulator that does the interrupting
and that's what makes them different
now the in the set they were in the
second in the first line there's a says
nasal now what you notice there is that
we allow in sub sounds the air to flow
through the know
we have open up a side port as it were
which allows the air to flow so the nose
and that excites certain resonances in
these cavities here and you have these
sounds like mmm-hmm you know these the
the so-called nasal sounds the rest of
the sounds are produced in such a way
that the soft palate is raised up and no
air is allowed to flow through the nose
and so we have this and that's and you
see what you what you're supposed to see
here is that we this is a particular
gesture that is the same in all three
types of sound so none more quite
similar in that their hair they are you
have a lowering of this soft palate but
in one case you superimpose this on a
labial stoppage of flow in the other
case you impose it on a coronal stop at
your flow and in the third case on a
dorsal stop is your flow I'm so yeah so
the the what you see here is that they
all they have a serf similar internal
structure now if you look at the non
nasal sounds you notice that two other
things you notice that sounds like and
two and four are produced without vocal
cord vibration now you can tell whether
your vocal cords vibrate when you say
they vibrate and you can feel that you
say they don't vibrate so there's
another property that this vocal cord
vibration that goes in and now you
notice again you can do that you can
vibrate your vocal cords while stopping
the airflow with your lips or while
stopping it with your flat part of the
tongue or the tongue body and you can do
that in different ways and finally there
and and that is represented by the
minuses and pluses in the second line
and that's it says something happens
that your glottis that you switch on and
off and these are the vocal cords
vibrators they don't and that's
represented online so now finally the
stoppage can be complete as it is let's
say art or it can be sort of partial as
it is and let's say where air is trapped
inside your mouth but only partially
okay now and the what you notice here is
that these are sort of sub gestures the
closure the lowering of the velum the
behavior of the vocal folds all these
each of these is represented in three
very in three variants in the first
class where the major closure is made
with the lips and second class words
made with the flat part of the tongue
in the third part where's performed with
a Tonga tongue body by raising the
tongue body and now these subjects you
find in all that's each phonemes
therefore is sort of a complex of
subjects and the technical term is to
say that phonemes are complexes of
features now so that a speech sound is
not something which is further
unanalyzed but rather it's a complex of
sub properties so now and and the
perhaps the most interesting observation
to be made is
of all the sounds in the world only
phonemes are complexes of features and
only complex and and only features or
they can be analyzed into phonemes and
they must be analyzed into phonemes so
when you hear to ask I mean what I what
does it when you represent let's say a
sound of you know the car or rattle in
your car you don't have phonemes to
represent that I mean some kind of
rattle that you know whereas words they
divided into phonemes and the phonemes
are made up of features that's sort of
the idea okay now this is this
digression this technical digression it
was necessary to bring out the next
thing now obviously none of you or most
of you who has has never heard of
phonemes before and I I'm here the first
to tell you now what's interesting is
that we now may ask a question do do
people who know English do they think
about the phonemes in terms of in
indivisible units or are our English
speakers in their naive
behavior is their behavior properly
characterized in terms of features and
here's an and we will try to show you
how that works now if the latter is true
then the knowledge that the people that
knew the plural rule that knew the rule
number three then of course they
wouldn't have lists of phonemes they
would have feature lists of some sort
that is they would know this knowledge
would not be represented by a list of
phonemes but the phonemes are always
feature bundles then they would be
represented by feature vowels so so for
example let's now look at five
five which is a translation of three
into features now notice the first set
is the sounds sir sure sir-sir charger
now all these sounds are made with a
flat part of the tongue they're coronal
they have the coronal feature and
moreover they have some other features
which we won't bother now okay so the
translation of the list the list that's
listing 3a ears as I've given in v
saying it's coronal does it have the
feature coronal plus some other features
okay now the second list says at Patoka
for now those are all the sounds and
only though that are made out without
vibration of the vocal folds they are
unvoiced and so the rule now has been
translated in terror into a feature that
means five is just a translation into
feature terms of that list that I've
given you in three and now the question
is in which form do you as a speaker of
English know the plural rule now the
answer and we'll have now run an
experiment right away and we will see
whether it works okay now the test was
suggested to be many years ago by Lisa
men who's now professor at the
University of Colorado and what she
tested she just was quite simple first
of all she said look you can ask people
to make plurals of non English words so
for example if you knew a Frenchman
whose name was de la yeah although you
doesn't exist in English you could ask
what's the plural of monsieur de la GUI
and his family and he there is somebody
so what is it which which one which one
but which one
the first the second or the third
ceremony okay fine good we're we're
getting there now
now the quiet
however let's have it not the two lists
make different predictions about this
sound e numbers three says regardless of
what the sound is if it's not an English
sound you have to make
that's what number three says but number
five doesn't say that number five says
look at its features if it has the
features then apply the rule okay so now
we have to find a phoneme of English
officer which not in English but which
has appropriate feature so it wouldn't
pick number three and we do have that
and everybody knows you're honza bustin
ba now ba he had many children and so
they're there and what's the plural of
ba number two not number three okay now
and that's clear that everybody picks
number two and not number three although
is not a phony of English therefore
there couldn't be a list
he couldn't be listed in anything that's
a rule of English and therefore since
the action was performed here and the
test was run here it's clear that
somehow or other people know something
about features maybe they had never
heard about it but then you know a lot
of things you haven't heard about that
you know play a real role in life okay
so we have now established that phonemes
are actually bundles of features and
that speakers have knowledge in a very
strong sense of these features they may
not have any way of talking about it but
then they we don't have any way of
talking about how we walk you know we
don't know how
how we balance ourselves so that we
don't fall down but we know how to do
that even though we can't talk about
okay now so what we have is our features
I mean that phoneme is a bundle of
feature and a word now we can now say
something about the way the word is
represented in memory namely be
represented by a matrix where each
column will represent a column of
features and there would be you know has
many phonemes each phoneme will be a
column of features and there'll be as
many phonemes in the word as there are
as many columns as there are phonemes in
the word so that's now the claim that
we're going to make about the
representation of words in memory now we
want to go on a little bit than say
little and perhaps a little bit more now
notice that the features are in one
sense they're instructions they're
instructions for actions that is in one
case that lower your vilem or close your
lips or their actions that are
observable actions now in memory of
course these instructions serve to
distinguish one word from another so the
difference between let's say the word
bill and the word mill is that in mill
we have the instruction lower your veal
m+ nasal whereas in bill it's - nasal
yes I mean that's the instruction but in
memories they serve as a kind of a
purely a diacritic mark which
distinguishes one matrix from another
and only at some particular point does
this this does it eventuate in action
now interestingly when you hear her
signal you there
for have to analyze the signal in in
terms of these actions in order to pick
the word out out of your memory if the
story is correct and the matrices are
matrices in terms of actions of
particular pieces of the machinery here
now you know that this so what what this
what this presupposes are implies is
that there is it's kind of a primacy of
the gymnastics that's going on over the
sound that's out there there's you
analyze the sound in terms of the
gymnastics in order to figure out what
which word must I did he say in order
for me to understand that person whose
speech I'm now understanding now this
may sound as rouser surprising
now some researchers have questioned the
need for the translation from acoustics
into articulations articulations
gymnastics and have proposed instead
that features in memory are directly
related to properties in the acoustic
signal rather than being indirectly
related to properties in the question is
therefore necessary at this point to
review the evidence that supports the
alternative view that there were named
for me since I have proposed that that
the acoustic signal is not directly
related to specific acoustic properties
in the in a signal but rather that this
relationship is in direct mediated now
this view by the way has a name in the
literature and it's called the motor
theory and it was been championed by
long term for a long time by Al
Lieberman of Haskins laboratory and a
number of other people that you may know
and now I will give a little bit of
evidence to write is indirect why I
think this is so that the there's a
primacy of the articulation over the
sound and the first evidence is when you
ask speakers of any language to say
word so you make our nonsense word like
soup let's say just made up some word
and you ask somebody to say it without
even in the dark so they can't see you
or you play a record so they can't see
what you do and they say please repeat
this word the actions that they perform
will be enormously uniform they be not
hundred percent over the uniformity is
enormously surprising so in the here's
that word they will start by raising the
flat part of the tongue up against the
roof of the mouth and they run around
their lips and and they raise this body
of the time I mean the the actions are
actually executed always the same
there'll never be an attempt you know to
mimic the sound by putting your fingers
in your mouth or doing something
desperate you know it'll always be the
uniform and this universal I mean
there's no instruction no no teaching
that that happens when you when you're
such a request might so it's very this
it's not only an English speaker but you
ask somebody who never spoke and never
heard English you tell them to pronounce
the Sun and there will be an enormous
uniformity and the uniformity will be in
terms of this execution of this
particular action now notice when you
ask people to produce a sound that you
make and I you make some odd sound and
say well see what you can do and you
know like scratching - piece of metal
place and reproduce this sound there
people get very lost they're very
flustered but you know we have this
built in there's certain sounds we
analyze into it articulatory gestures
mainly features and those we then
produce and then others you know we do
all kinds of wild things another bit of
experiment and evidence is the so-called
McGurk experiment that some of you may
know now the McGurk experiment consisted
of the following rather surprising
[Music]
test I'm a people heard I tape in it and
so they are shown a tape in the video
where somebody says dare dare dare dare
dare dare day at a particular time point
the pronoun the audio portion remains
the same but the video portion changes
somebody say like this you know saying
doo doo doo doo essentially although the
audio portion continues saying there
that and the impression that people have
is that the purse is switched and that
he's now saying doo doo doo and you can
actually you turn off the video and they
hear they dead that day again and you
turn the video up and it's serving an
illusion and the illusion simply shows
you that are the the articulatory
information the you once you receive
this articulatory cue I mean so
overwhelming that you think that you
hear something different so here's
another bit of some kind of evidence
that suggested now the third is what
happens in language and this is this my
last point I take about 10 minutes to to
make it and that is that in addition to
making plurals there are other kind of
rules in language and I'll begin by one
and these rules as you will see always
affect features they always affect one
or two features and as you'll see in
just a moment so take for example the
the words in six now notice when we say
take a word like leaf now the plural of
leaf happens not to be Leafs but it's
leaves you know we say chief Chiefs but
leaf leaves okay now the same thing will
take house
the plural of house is not houses that
would be the plural of Herman's and his
family but it would be its houses I mean
so what happens is that in the plural we
change the shape of the stem the the
noun in the plural is has a different
sound and in the singular so house in
the poorer in a singular but house in
the plural and we don't do it in now I
that's not reflected in the spelling but
notice for F and V we have even we
reflect that even in the spelling so we
say leaf but the plural is leaves and we
write a different letter there to
reflect that before house we don't
bother we don't write the Z there okay
there's a small number of English words
which have this property and in order to
speak English correctly you have to do
that if you said Leafs that somebody
would correct you that's not correct I
mean you so there is this kind of small
rule and we have a rule which I've
written in number seven and what the
rule says is that if you have a sound
such as plus continuant means that kind
of sound which has incomplete blockage
of the flow that this sound in the
plural becomes voiced it changes it
features company compositions so that
instead of being produced without vocal
cord vibration it's now produced with
vocal cord vibration so there is such
and that's part of knowing English okay
now interestingly there's other things
that affect voicing in English so let's
take the suffix that's spelled th which
you find on one hand in the ordinal
numbers so twelfths twelfths minus
twelve
but twelfths
say now or five and you say fifth it's
not five mm but fifth so there's a the
verb becomes fir which in speech turn
means it becomes voiceless and notice
the same thing happens in the when the
th is used to make a noun for an
adjective so we say why'd you say wits
but with C or broad breaths okay I mean
there other such examples all right now
what's interesting what sure is is that
here again we have in terms of features
what we would say is that the dis
consonant becomes - voice before the
suffix th you know this is a suffix th
but but here it's sort of wrong to put
it that way
because really what's going on here is
not this th is itself - voice you know
when we had this fear it inhere without
the feature composition but th itself is
a voiceless now what's going on here is
that the feature - voice is sort of
spread onto the preceding sound it's are
being anticipated as it were it's not
just any change that's going on here it
isn't as though you know this constant
becomes nasal or some crazy change the
change here is really a change of a
feature spreading from one phoneme onto
the other and what you have here is a
kind of an anticipation of voiceless you
know that this is going to be voiceless
so therefore you anticipated already
but now let's go back to the English
plural rule and notice what we had there
was we had we said well we get if it's -
voice then it becomes otherwise it's
remember that's what rule 35 said the
last part but again what you have here
say is spreading in the opposite
direction that is if the spreading in
air goes from the end of the stem on to
the suffix that is the suffix was or it
is the basic suffixes but if it's if it
follows a voiceless consonant then the
feature the voicing feature now is
spread on it so here you have a lot as
it were a kind of a perseverance and
inertia effect where this feature of the
stem is held over onto the suffix and
I've represented these two things in
your handout in one is in 10 and the
other one is in the eleven where I try
to show you that the in one case we have
kind of an anticipation effect and in
the other case we have a inertia effect
okay and now again is is that I want to
go on and show you our very surprising
and unexpected effect and that is when
we look at the actual gesture in begins
to make very good sense when we look at
the actual I say which I'm gonna now
tell you okay
now how do you do how is voicing
produced I mean you know we've I brait
our work of course how we do that well
you know we don't each vibration isn't
individually controlled they go much too
fast they go several hundred times a
second so it's it has to be done in some
other way and the way you do it is
basically
like the soul I mean what right it's a
kind of a relaxation isolation where you
blow air up from the lungs the vocal
cords sit on top of the lungs air
they're elastic as the pressure builds
up they their vocal cords are shelved
apart then some air escapes the pressure
drops and Bernoulli affected her vocal
cords close them you know the whole
thing starts all over again from the
beginning
so that's the actual action now Ken
Stevens and I who like Pete Elias and I
go back to God of you know prehistoric
times
so we some 25 years ago we investigated
the matter we studied this whole
question of how that works and one of
the things we noticed immediately and
this for this we claim no credit or we
shouldn't claim any credit is that I
mean then what happens as you stiffen
the vocal chords has just stiffened the
VOC of course what happens now
interesting the first thing that happens
is that the rate of vibration will
increase so as you make them stiffer the
rate of vibration increases now we know
that we've control what does it what
does the vocal cord vibration reflect
well when I increased my vocal cords the
let's say when I say of our vowel or
some any any vowel and I increase the
rate of vibration my vocal cord the
pitch goes up you know said oh oh oh
this is these are changes in the rate of
vibration that are affected probably by
that are by changing the stiffness of
the vocal cords now however and here's
the more interesting fact when you make
a vowel sound
you're as I indicated for you your mouse
is wide open no air is trapped in your
mouth and the pressure inside your mouse
is roughly ambient pressure and so the
drop from what goes on from the lungs
onto them or into the mouse is sort of
the maximum pressure than the difference
that can be now what happens when you
say let's say well you say you you trap
my you trap air in your mouth and some
pressure is built up inside your mouth
and therefore the drop across the vocal
folds assuming that the pressure in the
lungs remains the same is less so we
have two cases in a sound like we have a
small pressure drop and in the sound
like ah we have maximum pressure drop
and now the question we asked was what
happens as you change make the same
changes in vocal cord stiffness what
will be the behavior of the vocal cords
now we know in in the case of big
pressure drop there will be increasing
in the rate of vibration but in the case
of a little pressure drop small pressure
job what happens not surprisingly when
you think about it is that as you
increase the stiffness the vocal cords
stop vibrating because there's just not
enough push at this point to show the
stiffness is now so great that and the
pressure is so small that they simply
don't worry wait so that says that as a
gesture the change the difference is in
pitch there's high pitch versus low
pitch and voiceless Ness absence of
vocal cord vibration and presence of
vocal cord vibration are produced by the
same mechanism right that is
the same articulatory mechanism that is
involved in making changes in pitch is
present in making the difference
differentiating from zone from ver and
so on okay now that's simply the the
logic of the situation but now notice
what's interesting and if you're looking
number in your handout under 13 I've
sort of made a table there and I've said
this a large pressure drop and on the
Left I said stiff vocal folds of slack
vocal folds and it was a large pressure
drop higher rate of vibration richness
lower rate of vibration where is small
pressure drop absence of vibration
cessation of vibration presence of
vibration okay so but now notice
acoustically and here's the question
that we try to raise what has what has
primacy is it the gymnastics or is it
the sound okay now notice the sound is
very different I mean there's really
nothing in common between a high-pitched
vowel and the low pitch and a voiceless
consonant and a low-pitched vowel and
voiced consonant okay so here is
acoustically as they should go their
separate ways but from the point of view
of the mechanisms they seem to be going
the same way now it but we have even a
little bit of linguistic evidence to
show that perhaps that's the right way
to go and that is and this evidence is
given in your tale in these examples
from China a Chinese dialect in number
14 now what goes on there is you know in
the Chinese words in many of the chine
in the Chinese languages they are
differentiated by the pitch contours
that they have so they have a falling
contour or rising contour or an even
contour and that makes differences in
meaning I mean you know everybody knows
that
okay but now in this particular dialect
which is not the standard I mean which
is not the Mandarin standard dialect or
any of the it's a particular mo a
dialect now what you see there is this
that look on the left-hand column now
the the numbers indicate pitches so 5 is
the highest pitch and 1 is the lowest so
5 3 is a falling pitch and 3 5 is the
rising and 4 4 is even but now notice
you have these two sets of words and
they have falling even and rising and
they ain't coming to vary versions a
high pitch version when the soundest is
two and a low pitched version when the
sound is duh so in T in the word T they
have three versions of the word T and
you know right T and T and T and then
they have the same with D but the
register in which it happens so is it a
high register or a low register if you
will and that goes of course with the
voicing of the proceeding of the concept
if you have 2 which is the voiceless
consonant that is one that you form by
stiffening your vocal folds you now
spread this stiffening of the vocal fold
on to the following vowel and therefore
the pitch of the vowel goes up in the
other case you've slacken the vocal you
have a derp with slackening of the vocal
folds and as a result you spread that
over to the well and as a result the
pitch of the vowel drops so in fact the
rule there seems to be a rule in Chinese
which said you know spread that's
stiffening from the preceding consonant
on to the following vowel and that's it
so the rule is really just exactly like
the rule that we have for the english
plural only in the english plural we
swear we spread it among consonants and
leave the vowels alone as
whereas in Chinese we spread from a
consonant to the vowel and the results
are exactly as expected but implicit in
all this is that the gesture the
articulatory gymnastics is the primary
thing whereas the acoustic result is as
it were a secondary thing so this brings
me I'll just have one brief conclusion
I'll say that I've argued that words are
stored in memory as sequences of
discrete phonemes I've suggested that
phonemes are composed of more elementary
entities namely features I've attempted
to give some idea of the nature of the
features and I've discussed a number of
facts that suggest that the significant
part of the knowledge that speakers have
of their language involves features I
noted that because of its great
complexity it is implausible to assume
that the machinery involved in the
memorization in production of words is
learned by speakers instead it's more
plausible to assume that much of the
knowledge required for speaking is
innate hardwired in us at birth and
finally I gave some evidence to show
that the articulatory actions of the
different features have a more central
character to the functioning of
languages and there
[Applause]
your questions wait when does the
hardwiring set in it's different for
every simple you know I have a colleague
Kent Hale for whom he's 55 and hard
wiring has yet to begin and but for most
people it's around puberty puberty about
1213 well death notice that their
natural language is of course the
gesture now you see what we speak your
mom always tells you not to but most of
us do and it's and the the lack the
death you see they developed a language
which is every bit as complex as English
nothing I mean death that mutes do not
just sign words I mean they sigh English
words in the order in which the English
syntax with them they they have a sign
language which another memories in terms
of yeah of gestures and they happen to
have gestures of the upper body and the
hands rather than just yourself the lips
and those activecollab your side that we
use those of us
I'm here and this clearly and now as
because you well know that did these
children develop for them
deaf children of parents who are not
there they develop they learn sign and
they learn sign correctly although the
parents very often don't know how to
sign correctly and you know they're
because a lot of it is really innate in
them and we have these both parallel
channels of which the FIR for obvious
energetic reasons the spoken chatty the
one that we use for speaking is is used
to be preferred because you are you
moving much smaller masses you know when
you move your arms and your body I mean
you're really moving pounds you know
where is when you move this you just
move a few grams in and their first much
more efficient from that point of view
so that's the preferred one but sign
languages have existed and exists there
just every bit as complicated as other
languages is the memory in terms of all
these words which is very large are than
in terms of features or whatever and
features and rules which which can
combine things
what's known about well what I showed
you is that the representation would
have to be in terms of some feature I
mean we are extremely gifted enormous li
gifted for memorizing enormous numbers
of words you know the average child age
six knows something like I don't know
thirty thousand words and that's an
enormous number you know when you think
that that child I mean there's stages
and children's little everywhere they
learn something like a word in an hour
and new word an hour those of you who've
taken language courses and had had to
memorize words we all know what a
horrible
difficult task that is and so we're very
capably naturally very gifted at
memorizing thousands and thousands of
words when you're when and at a young
age and the rules of language like those
that I showed you are very obviously in
terms of features a feature changes
because you spread the food you spread
this feature onto some adjacent phoneme
as I tried to show you or things like
that that's what goes huh sir
jeunesse Co mastic question now how do
you explain roof roofs and hoo-hoos or
the fact that we'd use a different
plural for the word loaf depending on
its meaning yeah we there are as I said
if you didn't get the handout with a
number seven I said that or number six I
forget not with numbers what yeah yeah
number seven I said that there's a list
I said notice applies only to leaf
there's about thirty words where this
rule applies and it's part of you have
to memorize I mean a large part of
English is memorization child will
probably do that go look the child
notice children will make mistakes and
the mistakes so for example you probably
if you've seen children will say Mouse's
now notice they never heard Mouse's or
they'll hear Oxus you know they'll say
Oxus they never heard Oxus because the
the language around them doesn't use
that they've said episodes that I mean
that goes again to show that they had
know the rule and they've learned the
rule and they haven't learned this the
exception rule namely that fur ox you
don't do it you know so they just go by
the regular rule until somebody takes
them aside and says hey
[Laughter]
yes I do but that's a long story I mean
I'll tell I you see me privately I'll
tell you but I mean that's that's a lot
yeah it's it's a shortening thing these
are they're partly shortening and other
things too and I but that's a lie I
would take me ten minutes to do it so
it's not appropriate to talk about
things like syllable structure or stress
pattern
I assume that's because you would group
it under your romantical no no I just
I only this is you know less than not
less than one could you come back yes I
can comment that don't know what I
I think syllable structure and stress
are what I believe is this that now I
can't give you any evidence needless
therefore this for not if that the
representation see I've said that the
representation is a form of a matrix you
know so each phoneme is is sort of a
block of features and that's what I said
now I oh I think that the way a proper
way to think about this even somewhat
different namely that this block of that
there's a timing slot associated with
each phoneme and the blocks of features
are associated was a timing slot and so
it's possible for example for a given
phoneme to be associated with two timing
slots like for example when you say oh I
don't know say Cooley or something like
this you know cool plus leaf you know
our
things like that okay where the phoneme
gets spread a given for him gets spread
over two slots and things lower now
syllable structure I I think is that is
imposed on on these timing slots and is
represented on a plane that sir saga
Nell to the plane in which the the
feature composition is and stress is yet
on another plane which is orthogonal to
so that the actual if you want to have
physical pictures like the knowledge
that you have of a word is like a spiral
bound notebook which is all you know the
registration is all in terms of these
timing slots and there's various
structure so off the timing starts and
you can peek I mean you can look from
one page to the other these pages and so
you just you look at something here and
decide what to do about the stress and
so on and they have vast interesting
specific properties and this is a tie
the syllable structure is a particular
kind and I've written about this and so
on but that's kind of a short answer to
a very long question
- so you sort of argued that phony
representations like not the acoustic
acoustic signal well I I said that
there's something that there's knowledge
of language versus independent of
speaking you know like for example
conceivable that you could be you would
have a let's say an injury or somebody
would have an injury and that wouldn't
would not permit that person to speak
you know some neurological injuries just
simply block any speaking the person was
still no English perfectly well couldn't
just couldn't perform the the the
actions but the actions would still be
represented by the language acts and so
in terms of these features and the
features are related to accents whether
they can be carried out or not
after couple trials they sort of adjust
yes and no so yes or no yes to some
extent too but also they never make a
tea by wizard lips swords will never
make a be with their body by
manipulating the feel of see they're
enormous
I mean there's there is some plasticity
and I but the plasticity is very limited
see I mean there you're absolutely right
I mean there is this plasticity and and
but the plasticity is sure but they
better III look if there's a real reason
why deaf people don't speak you know I
mean it's the acoustics triggers it I
mean so I I said they're you know I
don't miss I didn't mean to say that you
don't have to listen if you don't hear
you can't you never works but there's
this very close tie up between the
acoustics and the articulation that's
what what I try to stress
features no but as the features are
actions
the features are acts they represent
those features and the features our
accents which have acoustic consequences
all right and I don't want our not for a
moment do I deny that
[Applause]